için ben sizden bir 10 saniye için
gözlerinizi kapatmanız rica ediyorum
Gözleri kapatalım
o o
Evet şimdi
11 milyon dolarınız var biri size bir
milyon dolar hediye etti dünya için ve
bu milyon doların gözleri açıldı lütfen
o Kimin yanında var
bu hesabınıza giriyor
Ben bugün yolda vardı neler
yapabileceğinizi hayal etmek için üç
saniye daha gözleri kapatır lütfen
İyi geceler açalım şimdi çoğumuz
Eğer bu tarz bir ev hayal etmiş
olabiliriz
Bu bir kısmı uzun zamandır almayı en
fazla arzu ettiğimiz Yüksel Bey almayı
hayatmış olabiliriz
bu vardığımız markayı çok seven bizim
ismim şimdiden bir tanesi var mı yapmak
zaten markalar almak için ve bundan
dahada fazlasını almak için hayaller
kurmuş olabiliriz
ve Aslında bilmiyorum duvarla Afrika'da
açlıktan Ölmek üzere olan ilmi internet
çocuğun hayatını kurtarabilir Uz bugün
dünyada Türkiye'de Okul yaptıranlara
teşekkür etmek lazım hepimiz zannediyor
ki okul yaptırmak Çok kolaymış 16
derslikli okulun maliyeti milyon dolar
a571 Ağaç deyince bir şey anlamayabilir
sana 570.000 aşık bir orman Ankara'da
Çankaya'nın büyüklüğünde bir alanı
kapsıyor 1 milyon dolarla 570.000 aşık
bir orman otobüsü Bu arada bir yanılgı
var hani açtım ben oradan yaptım falan
kestiğim ağaçlar yerine ya da yanaştır
öyle olmuyor bir orman oluşması için
toplam 35 sene geçmesi gerekiyor Yani
ağaçlar yüzecek onların kökleri
birbirine diyecek bu köklerinden
birbirine konuşacaklar yaprakları
üstünden tohum verecekler rüzgarlı
etrafa yazacak o zaman orman oluyor o
zaman ekosistem kurtuluyor O yüzden
ağacı kestik yaktık yere diktik la orman
oluşturamıyoruz Maalesef şimdi gündemi
konulardan bir tanesi sokak hayvanları 1
milyon dolar ancak Sokak 40 bin tane
Sokak hayvanı birazcık incelenir
37 Afrika'da 75 bin kişinin bir aylık
müzik ihtiyacını bilmiyorlar
karşılaşabiliyoruz Biz bunu yapmak yine
ne yapıyoruz ya da ne yapıyoruz biz
tüketiyoruz ne tüketiyoruz bizim
birazcık aldığınızdan bir tanesi de
serpilip ve kahvaltılar açık büfeler
Türkiye'de 240 milyon lira her sene
ziyan oluyor açık büfe veya serpme
kahvaltı lardan dolayıp İşte bizim
işlerimizin bir tanesi Reklam yapıyoruz
marka tüketimi işte karar cumalar Black
Friday ile iş 14 Şubat Sevgililer Günü
alalım daha fazla alalım ama alsak da
dolabımızda böyle ara ayakkabıların
sırasını Dursun bunların bir tanesi de
iki tanesi giyelim bunu çok düşünüyorum
Çünkü biz çocukluktan itibaren başarıya
başarıyla bitti gelen hücre güçle
birlikte gelen paraya ekonomik gücünde
karşılığında tüketmeye örüyoruz
o araba herkes trafikten şikayetçi ama
trafikte tek araba içinde tek kişi
gördüğümüz bir sürü arabalar ve bir
trafik sıkıntılar İzmir'de var Eskiden
bir 15 sene önce İzmir'de trafik sıkıntı
yoktu ama şimdi artık İzmir yazlık da
işe giderken İş dönüşü trafikte
buluşmaya başladı Bunun etkilerine ne
oluyor ve çevreye zarar veriyoruz çöp
yığınları oluşuyor
Bu plastik en büyük farklardan bir
tanesi ama biraz Çiftlik ediyoruz
artıyor bugün baktığımız zaman burada
işte bir sudan hepsini biraz kişilerde
var peki bunun neticesinde bizim
O bizim geldiğimiz bu noktada
en son 2027 konuşuyoruz işte doğal
afetler felaketler bunları sebebi ne
düşünüyoruz ama yani doğal afet olduğu
zaman bir yere kaybettiğimiz zaman tabi
canımız acıyor empatide Minaj araca
empati kuruyoruz ama bir bağ kuruyoruz
Bağ kurmamız İçinde esasta anlık
yaşıyoruz o duygularım yani o yüzden ki
anlık yaşıyoruz sonra uzun testi veren
olaylar unutuyoruz ya da o üzüntüye
sebep veren ailem derinliğine inmiyoruz
bakmıyorsun ne olduğunu ama böyle
yaşamaya devam edersek Dünyamız bakalım
ne olacak kuraklık sel
ve Avustralya'daki orman yangınları
konuşup durduk ama bu yangınlar biz
böyle devam edersek bitmeyecek susmayıp
20 TL karşılığı ama hala Buna çözüm
bulabilmiş değiliz buzulların erimesi
gördüğünüz bütün felaketten ana sebebi
iklim değişiminin sebebi buzullar ama
buraya gelene kadar o tüketim ben
kaynaklı konular bunların bazıları çözüm
bulamıyoruz Neden bulamıyorsun ekonomi
her zaman daha ön planda kalıyor bu
savaş bir Corona virüsü ile ilgili bir
sürü konu var esasta seyahatlerin
engellenmesi lazım da çok daha önceden
bir çok makale bunu söylüyor fakat
ekonomi durmasını bunu yapamıyoruz
ve ekonomik durması ne birçok şey
yapamadığımız için Dünyamız bir Uçurumun
Kenarına gelmiş vaziyette bir anı
yaşamaya devam edersek buradaki insanlar
olarak bir şey olmaz 25 üstündeyiz bizim
çocuklarımız için bu dünyayı uçurmaya
aşağıya gideceğiz ya da dünyayı
kurtarabilmek için bir şeyler yapacağız
biz çocuklar başladılar bile yapmaya bu
yazınız Bu hareketi Her cuma başladı bu
işte kız gerçek mi değil mi
tartışmalarını devam ediyor şu anda Ama
onlar daha farkındalar artık kendi
geleceklerine sahip çıkmak istiyorlar
peki bunun nedenlerinden bir tanesi
nedir diye baktığımız zaman 1819'da
Dünya nüfusu sadece bir insanda
oluşuyordu 2119 da 11 milyon insan doğru
gidiyoruz Şu anda 7.7.8 bir insan var
dünyada dünyanın kaynaklarını esas da
baktığın zaman 7 milyar insan
yapabilecek durumda fakat başka bir
sorun var hayatımızda o da isterse gelir
dağılımı eşitsizliği
bugün baktığımız zaman dünyanın gecenin
yaklaşık yüzde 40 ikisini 54 milyon kişi
oluyor arkadaşlar yani hangileri
neredeyse yarısını Türkiye nüfusu az bir
grup alıyor geri k142 593 milyon kişi
alıyor
ya ondan sonra 5.2 milyar kişi 5.2
milyar kişi dünya gelir Sadece yüzünü
alıyor
ne dedik yani tüketim buna bu kadar
ihtiyacımız var mı diye su Vakıflar
bunlar için kuruluyor sastamala kızlar
kurana kadar Bunlar çok daha farklı
şekilde yönetme imkanı esasta insanlar
aksabis nasıl sahibiz düğün sonunda
dünya için insanlık için bir ışık var mı
yoksa bundan 11 sn sonra Elmas için
doğum Peygamberi gibi bahsedecek karıştı
insanları aldı hayvanları aldım arsa
götürdü dünya yok oldu orada hayat devam
etti Sonra geri geldiler ya anlatılacak
mı Bak şimdi esasta dijitalleşme ile
birlikte hayatımıza giren yeni bir
kavram var Bu da paylaşım yapabilirsiniz
nedir paylaşmak ve üstü Bizim
tüketmenizi daha kontrol altına alacak
ihtiyacımız daha fazlasını tüketmenizi
durdurabilecek bir yöntem
Bu nasıl mı bu yurtdışındaki artık yaşam
şekillerine görüyorsunuz insanlar Araba
almaktan vazgeçtiler aramaktansa
paylaşımlarda kullanıyorlar farklı
markaları servisleri var arabaları
çağırıyorlar arabayı çağırıyorsunuz
kendi şoförü gibi her gün farklı bir
boyut deneyimi yaşayabiliyorsunuz
Böylece arabanın sigortasından
maliyetinden bakımından gerisi benzin
acımasından ve gereksiz enerji
tüketiminden kurtuluyorsunuz kendisi
paylaşım ofisler hayatımıza girdi
paylaşım ofisler aynı zamanda saat
hapların yan girişimleri yeni işlerin
kurulmasında çoğalttı bu giriş ve kas
için çok önemli şey Çünkü ilk başta
baktığınız zaman en büyük maliyet bir
şirket kurmaktaki ya da bir fikri hayata
geçirmekte ki acaba ben başarısız
olursam bu yaptım yatırımları boşuna
yapacağım Bu paylaşımlı ofis ortamları
yla bunun bu Mahallesi aşağı iniyorsun
ve gereksiz tüketimden de kendini
kurtarmış olursunuz şimdi Türkiye'de
karşılaştığı bir süre emlakvar Atıl
kaldı Bunları kim olacak ki
O ne olacak ve bütün inşaatlar
yapıldıktan sonra ortada bir yeşil de
kalmıyor o yüzden hem çevreye hem de
edeceğimiz de fayda olan bir paylaşım
ekonomisi sistemi ile daha farklı iş
hayatında çözümler bulabiliriz Çünkü
kıyafetler Hanımlar çok iyi bilirler en
büyük sıkıntılardan bir tanesi bir
davete düğüne giderken bir elbise almak
ve o elbiseyi işte bir kere gidiyorsunuz
gittiniz bir davette belki kere
diyorsunuz sonra dolapta nasıl duruyor
dünya kadar para veriyorsunuz şu
paylaşmak ödemesi mantığında gene
teknoloji bize getirdiği faydaların bir
tanesi Ateş sağlıyorsunuz elbisesi
kiralaya biliyorsunuz kiralama elbise
size geliyor gayet güzel temizlenmiş bir
şekilde üst üste görebiliyorsunuz Burada
en çok kullananlar kimler biliyor
musunuz ünlüler
bu en çok parası olanlar Buradan daha
çok faydalanıyor başka bir şey diye
düşünebilir Ah şimdi bunu başkası ile
elbisemi giyeceğim Araya bir şey yok bu
elbise yepyeni bir elbise giyebilirsiniz
kullanabilirsiniz bunu yani çok yapayım
çok parası olanlar da bunu sistemden
faydaları var zaten şimdi inşaat
şirketleri aç ortak kullanım alanlar
yapmaya başladı baktığınız zaman esasla
evinizde ihtiyacımız anneye gelişe yatak
odası banyo bu ufak bizi ağırlama
kültürü vardı kocaman savunduğunuz olsun
diye Ben çocuk yani hatta şey vardı
babaannemin evine giderdim eşya üstü
örtülü durdu böyle neden derdim eski
misin diye başkası gelecek onu
ağlayacaksın Ama kendime şey
kullanmayacağım böyle bir böyle bir
yanlışlık vardır Hatta televizyona Ozan
da böyle üstüne bir televizyon tül
atarlar daha bir anlamaz ne olduğunu
Çünkü o çok önemli bir şeydi alınmasını
Zordu Ama şimdi artık şu Mümkünse
Türkiye'de inşaat firması yapmış ismini
vermem eklem olsun diye şöyle bir şey
yapıyorlar
bu aşağıda büyük ağırlama yerleri var
catering servisi var garsonlar falan
davet vereceğimiz zaman geliyorsunuz
burada ekonomik bir şekilde bulabiliyor
oraya misafirliğe alıyorsunuz Böylece ki
gereksiz yere 3 O da artı 1 salon ya da
büyük evler almak zorunda kalmıyorsunuz
ekonomi ediyorsunuz Şimdi bunlar da bir
şey geliyor insanların bunu yapar mı
İşte oyun odaları var oyun olana gerek
yok Çünkü zaten bu inşaatın içerisinde
var ortak spor yapabileceğiz alanlar
yaşam alanı içerisinde var Bu da da
enteresan artık inşaat firmaları
sıkıntısı var diyoruz mali işler devam
bahsediyoruz finansmandan bahsediyoruz
biz buna yurt dışında daha önce
farkındalık oluşmuş ve yatırım yapmışlar
şu Türkiye'de bir grup yapıyor Bunu at
İnşaat makineleri Çünkü kepçe ne zaman
lazım size gerçeği inşaatı ne zaman
lazım Kanka zaten devir-temlik kazarken
bunu alıyorsunuz yaşattın başı üç ay
dört ayrı çok büyük inşaat yaptınız alt
açma bu yatıyordu
ya o yüzden ne yapıyoruz başka bir
inşaat projesi başlayacağız Maviler
Şimdi bunu bundan kurtarışlar sistemi
aciz bu makine kiralama biliyorsunuz
Hatta bunu kullana operative kilo
alıyorsunuz böyle kepçe geliyor sizin
şarkınızı işini bitirin yandaki inşaata
geçiyor Ayşe vinç için de geçerli aynı
şey diğer İnşaat ürünleri için de
geçerli Böylece hem gereksiz bir maliyet
ten kutluyorsunuz hem gerisi toptan
kurtuluyorsunuz hem de bir paylaşım
yapıyorsunuz şimdi bütün bunları
anlattım ama insanların kafasında şöyle
büyük bir soru vardı şeyi söylüyorsun
güzel Sözde insan değişir mi Bizim
duamız bugüne kadar değişmemiş bişey
esasta insan değişir Arkadaşlar neden
değişebiliyor musunuz şimdi vegan trendi
var
Evet bu da bir çantaya Biz pazarlarız
labirent yaratmak Sağlıklı beslenmek
için 10 10 insanlar vegan beslenme
mischler şimdi devam bir dönem sana
yiyorduk Ondan sonra tereyağı 7 yumurta
faydalı mı değil her gün gazete Bunlar
yapıyorsunuz zaten ney faydaları nedir
var ya
ne olmuş önce insana ekliyorsunuz Avcı
olarak başlamışlar hayvanlar alıyorlar
Sonra çıkıyorlarmış Ateş geçirmişler son
bu da keşfedilmiş
Bu evin hep şey var elimde
Ama şöyle bir şey oluyor
Ben buradayım bize ilk başta oturmamış
bir sürü insan da burada yemekten
oluyormuş Çünkü sistemlerinde ise Gülten
Gülten çökelek şimdi konuşmalar ama
insan vücudu yaşayan Şu anda biz
yaşayanlar buna evrim geçirmiş olarak
geliyoruz Yani biz buradan yemeğe yakın
bir topluluk şu anda et yemeyi pişirmiş
olarak yaptığı toplumuz şimdi vegan o bu
Tartışma geleceğim sadece şu iş
anlatıyor bunu İnsanoğlu değişebiliyor
ve evrimleşiyor ilişiyor yani evimde
esaslara fiziksel olarak başlasa da
beyinde başlar Çünkü bunun temelinde
beyin var İnsan vücudunun Hemen de beyin
var İlaçlar eserse birleştiriyorlar
ilaçlar bizim vücudumuzu eleştirdikleri
süreçte vücudun kendisi olan varsa
yardımcı oluyorlar vücudu iyileştiren
şey kendi mekanizması Çünkü mükemmel bir
de
bu çünkü niye sonraki Işık olursa
dönersek buradan değişebilir miyiz Evet
değişebiliriz sıkı bir video izleyeceğim
nasıl değişebileceğini zordan
anlatacağım O
mi Evet Şu esas burada olan ve
biliyorsunuz Bisiklete binmek herkes kim
bisiklete bilmediği var mı bisiklete
biniyor hiç Herkes bir şeyler yaklaşık 2
bin herhalde burada bisküvi bilmiyorum
atabilir misiniz
son değil mi buradayız şimdi video
gösteren nasıl olabildiğini gösteriyor
O nasıl oluyor bisikletin gidonunu
çıkartıyor ters bakıyor yani bisikleti
saç evinizde sonra gidiyor tamam
en son çevrenize sağ gidiyor ve bebeğin
bir bunu tutuyor çünkü otomatik maçlara
gitmek için sonra dönmek istiyor ama
gidemiyor vücut ona göre kendi konulan
düşüyor Çünkü dengede kalması lazım
İstediğin gitmez lazım Kendisine bunu
tekrar öğretmesi 8 ay sürüyor 8 ay sonra
o beyin bunu tekrar yapa yapa ama bir
şey bildiği bir şeyi unutuyor ve
öğreniyor ve fiziksel olarak adapte
oluyor vücut hastalığı gelmesi gibi
esaslı
var ama çocuğu öğretmesi
13 hafta sürüyor Çünkü çocuklarımızı
Zihni taze de şimdi Aksu'nun başına bir
sürü kullan bahsettim işte paylaşım
kümes için sondaki ışık ve ışık olup
olmadığı
bu ne Ben bugün size bırakacağım sürenin
sonunda çünkü Eğer siz önce Kendinizden
başlayın
ve yaşayacağımız potansiyel sıkıntıları
da görerek ten hayatınızda belli küçük
fedakârlıklarla
bu çocuklarınıza Bağkur'u daha da
önemlisi çocuklarının geleceği için
kendinize bağ kurup çocuklarınıza
öğretmeye başladı zaman bu konuları yani
sadece Başımıza bir felaket geldiği
zaman değil
bu üzüm hayatın normal akışı içerisinde
bunları Paylaştığınız zaman
bir insan kendini değiştirebilir bir
çocuk bir öğretmen bir kalem ve kitap
dünyayı değiştirir ben buna çok
inanıyorum Umarım Sizlerde inandırabilir
mi şimdi bir teşekkür ediyorum